and we are back
hey you guys merry christmas
yep i can't believe that we haven't
talked about this movie but actually i'm
kind of glad that we haven't because
now we can use this for the christmas
episode because this is going up um on
actual christmas day unless you're a
patron
yeah this is a classic this is a classic
one it's a
i think the reason why we haven't done
it is just because it's it's kind of a
given
i think everybody's reviewed this one
huh probably yeah
there's a [ __ ] ton of reviews of this
and of the sequel and stuff like that
movies gremlins
gremlins now somebody sent us this
it might have been louie or it might
have been michael
or it might have been because i'm trying
to think of like because there's a
couple of our fans out there that always
send us a bunch of movies yeah there's a
blu-ray
4k and we got yeah the 4k blu-ray like a
while back so i've been wanting to
review this for a while but i was gonna
do it before but then i was like oh i
should save it until christmas and we
should do it for christmas time because
it's
essentially like a christmas movie takes
place around christmas time
although you know what's dumb this
always like freaked me out it doesn't
freak me out but you know
this came out in 1984 and it came out in
the theaters
in june of 1984. why did they not put it
out at christmas time
who [ __ ] knows maybe they couldn't
get the slot i guess not
this actually came out the same day as
ghostbusters
really ghostbusters was number one and
this movie was number two man it's funny
i didn't remember that
1984 was a hell of a year yeah i think
beverly hills cop
ended up being maybe was in the top four
that year also
okay but it's gonna come out the same
time but this but gremlins and
ghostbusters came out on the exact same
day isn't that crazy
and those are both like you know [ __ ]
classics yeah
from uh the 80s and the fact they came
out the same day that just like blows my
phone yeah
that whole time man it's just kind of
blurs together you know
i kind of forget what came out in what
order and what was going on at the same
time
me too like wasn't wasn't flash gordon
in around this time too
i thought flash gordon was much earlier
earlier i thought flash gordon was late
70s
no early 80s no it was early 80s it
might have been 8283 something like that
yeah this was 84. okay now the weird
thing about this though is that i
distinctly remember seeing ghostbusters
in the theater
but i don't think i saw this one in the
theater i'm not entirely sure why
because this would have been right up my
alley
i would have been like how old would i
have been i was 12 when this came out
and i remember seeing ghostbusters in
the theater but not this one
which is really weird maybe we could
only afford to go to one movie a week
and this was so
and ghostbusters was the one we saw so
we didn't see gremlins i saw it later i
saw it like a year or two later on cable
or vhs or something
yeah so this movie was directed by joe
dante
now as well known as joe dante is
nowadays particularly for doing
horror comedy he also did the burbs
which we reviewed
the only really major thing he had done
before this movie was the howling
uh which had been in 1981. and
then he kind of went into this little
career lull a little bit
now the interesting thing about this
[ __ ] script the gremlin script which
was actually much darker
like one when it started out which i'll
get into in a bit
but this script was written and it
originally wasn't even supposed to be
made into a movie it was written as a
spec script
that like you know because writers
that's like screenwriters will write a
spec script
so they can go around to producers and
say hey look i can actually write a
screenplay but that's not necessarily
the movie that's going to get made
right but for what for somehow
like steven spielberg ended up reading
the screenplay and thinking it kicked
ass
so he's like i'm just gonna buy this and
make this into a movie
and so he was the producer on it and he
wanted joe dante to direct it
because joe dante had already done
horror comedy with the howling
um and even though he didn't really get
known for horror comedy until
after this movie came out because he
also made the burbs like i said and some
other things
but i guess the howling made enough of
an impression on steven spielberg that
he wanted him for this material
so i thought that was kind of
interesting too so i guess like the dude
that wrote it
he was kind of like i got the idea not
only from
uh i guess it was a book by roald dahl
that came out in the 1940s that was
called the gremlins
and you know gremlins were kind of like
a world war ii thing
like you know when machinery like you
know you know airplanes [ __ ] like that
failed there was oh it's little gremlins
or whatever and of course they had that
twilight zone
glitches yeah like glitches but they
were attributing to like
little speakers monsters little spirits
and um so he kind of got the idea to do
that
now like i said the original screenplay
and it's funny because i have seen this
movie a lot of times
um but i watched it again last night and
i hadn't seen it for several years and i
always forget
how violent it is yeah like
it's technically not supposed to be a
kids movie
but it also kind of comes across like a
kids movie
but then it's like there's some like
really crazy like
horror [ __ ] in there which i think is
really funny they did a lot of stuff
that you wouldn't do today
yeah and uh when i saw him put the damn
head of the gremlin in the fireplace and
it was burning and melting i was like
damn
i i forgot i forgot that that's how the
80s rolled even though i
grew up during that time that wasn't
unusual i was just like yeah burn it
[Laughter]
nowadays they wouldn't they wouldn't
they wouldn't put that in a movie you
know they thought look
that they thought would attract kids i
think well i think we were hardcore back
then
well back then there was actually it's
funny to think about now because
it's it's such a classic now but back
then there was a lot like a lot of pearl
clutching like a lot of parents hey i
took my four-year-old to see what i
thought was gonna be this cute kids
movie
by the dude that made e.t and it has
like cute little a cute little maguire
in it and then all of a sudden
you know gremlins are getting like
chopped up and
in the [ __ ] mixer and like blown up
in the microwave and [ __ ] like that i
was a kid when i saw it i didn't give a
[ __ ]
i thought it was cool i was like yeah i
was a teenager i guess
yeah that's the thing i was i was 12
when this came right so it's not like it
was any kind of traumatizing
anything like that i could see how if
you were four and you thought it was a
kids movie about a cute sweet little
creature that sings and like
you know talks all cute and everything
and then suddenly it took a hard left
turn into horror
i can see how maybe that could be
traumatizing if you're four i didn't
really think it was horror but
it's a it's more like sci-fi it's a
comedy horror it's basically what it is
it's like a black comedy but it's also
an homage to
50s b movies like monster movies because
joe dante is really really into those
cheesy old
50s b movies and he even put like a
bunch of them
in the background of this you know what
i mean like on tv
and [ __ ] like that yeah oh i wanted to
say that because i
as many times i've seen this movie and
i'm glad that some other people on
youtube have pointed this out because i
never noticed this until we were
watching it last night
the one scene where the dad where uh
billy's dad
is at the you know invention convention
or whatever the [ __ ] it is
and you know i noticed like the robot
from forbidden planet okay because that
like walks in front i noticed the steven
spielberg cameo who goes by in the
wheelchair or whatever
but i didn't i never noticed in the back
i noticed the time machine like from the
movie
the time machine that you know the hg
wells one the movie that came out with
uh what's his face like robert taylor
was that guy's name i can't remember
that actor's name
but that was in it what i didn't notice
was that in the next scene
the time machine was gone and there's
smoke and there's smoke and then there's
two people dressed in kind of like 40s
clothes going where the [ __ ]
yeah yeah like where did the time she
worked i did not
notice that until last night and i just
like laughed and left yes
i noticed the time machine but i didn't
notice that it was gone like in the next
one
so i thought that was like really really
funny but there's all kind of like you
know there's um
on the tv like during the movie there's
some [ __ ] from like invasion of the body
snatchers and there's all that kind of
stuff
i mean because essentially what this
movie is it's like a christmas version
it's kind of like
it's got a little bit of it's a
wonderful life in it but it's also like
kind of like the blob because it's just
kind of like this infection that like
takes over the whole town
yeah and even the way that it was shot
because it's it was shot all in a set
and um
you know it was shot like warner
brothers studios like the back lot and
everything this it's the same backlot
that they use for back to the future
um you know what i mean so so you can
see it looks kind of familiar like the
movie theater and stuff
so they set it all up like that but he
wanted
us he wanted that kind of look he wanted
a fake look because he wanted it to look
like
old movies that were all shot on sets so
and and if you see like the long shots
like of the um of the town like kingston
falls and stuff
there's uh like the backgrounds are
matte paintings like to make the town
look bigger i remember one i remember
seeing this as a kid and the special
effects really blew me away back then
like the
the way the gremlins the puppets the
puppets and
um i was amazed you know i see it now
and i'm like uh
i i recognize all the truth well you
know how they do it i know how to do it
now you know
but uh i was like how'd they get those
arms to move like that
well the little wire is so thin and the
camera can't pick it up yeah they're
there's different kinds of puppets right
yeah they basically they built the set
some of the sets they had to build like
three or four feet off the ground so you
could have like puppeteers underneath
yeah
so you know if you had if you were
interacting with a puppet that was down
here and you didn't have to see the
floor then obviously the puppeteer would
be underneath just like on the muppets
yeah and back in those days i was quite
impressed i was very impressed well i
see it now and i'm just like it's it's a
good
yeah it still looks good i think the
effects are still good
but they didn't look as good as i
remembered them back then but
i don't know if it was because you were
i was watching it on crt tvs a lot and
it just
kind of hid the kind of plasticky
textures of the bodies
i remember them looking real they don't
really look real
yeah they look good but they don't look
real they look like like i said it's
kind of like
muppets in the sense that you know that
they're not real like they're obviously
puppets
but they still have a life to them so
it's very easy to suspend your disbelief
and saying these are like real little
creatures
because when i watch it i don't think
about oh there's a puppeteer
i'm just like oh it's just like a little
monster running around back in the day
when
back in the day these these uh
these special effects were [ __ ]
state-of-the-art yeah people were just
like amazing blown away by it yeah
i mean but and like i said this coming
out the same day as ghostbusters which
had the amazing [ __ ] stay puft
marshmallow man
yeah that looks thing that looks really
good and everything too which was just
just done with miniatures and
you know back projection or you know
green screen or whatever but it's like
and that still looks amazing
but this i mean like i said it's a
combination of what they did when they
did close-ups
they would have like the head was bigger
so some of the puppets they just had the
heads like
like gizmo's head and stripes head they
just had one that was just a head
but it was bigger and they used like
servos and stuff like to control the
face because
the smaller puppets they wanted them to
be little
because i think the puppeteers
complained initially to joe dante and
was like
can we please like make these creatures
like gizmo and stuff can we make them
bigger because it's such a pain
like to get them to move realistically
but they're because
they're so small and joe dante was like
no no it's like
gizmo particularly has to be that small
because his cuteness is like the whole
kind of thing
to it so they can't make him bigger so
they had to like make some bigger
versions of his head like for
close-ups and whatnot so you could see
like the expression in his face
so basically what i was gonna say too is
that the original version of this
screenplay
i mean and we mentioned before like i
like i said if you haven't seen gremlins
i don't know where the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] planet you're from because
i feel like everybody has seen this
[ __ ] movie at least once at least
older people have seen it at least older
people have seen it and i feel like a
lot of younger people have seen it too
because like i said a lot of
uh younger people that i've seen like
review movies like on your their youtube
channels like pretty much everybody has
one for this yeah everybody's kind of
going back to the 80s and the 90s stuff
that was going
going on anyway there's classic era yeah
so i'd be very very surprised if you
hadn't seen gremlins like i said i know
that there's probably some people that
haven't but
you know it's it's just i feel like it's
an american classic and everybody needs
to see it at least once
but as dark as this movie is like i said
uh you know the original batch of
gremlins
that comes from you know gizmo
they all get killed by billy's mom
because billy's mom don't take no [ __ ]
from no kremlins said she just [ __ ]
like i said she blows one up in the
microwave she likes
she decapitates one and like the head
goes into the fire
and [ __ ] like that so and people do die
in this like the gremlins kill people
they kill billy's
science teacher they kill that
cranky old bat that was played by polly
holliday who was flo
on alice i was like man flo's such a
[ __ ] in this i forgot
but uh you know so people who die in
this but in the original screenplay
um billy's mom was actually killed and
decapitated
by the gremlins and like billy came home
and like his mom's head like rolled down
the stairs
uh in the original screenplay the
gremlins also ate billy's dog
which i was kind of like the dog got
kind of abused in this one too like
because i think the gremlins like tied
him up in all the christmas lights and
he was out there like hanging which kind
of i was like oh [ __ ] that's upsetting i
didn't
remember that being in there but um but
there was all kind of other [ __ ] like
that where it was like way more
mayhem like a lot of people got killed
like in horribly horribly violent ways
so i guess once they decided to go in a
little bit of a more black comedy
direction
they decided to tone down the violence a
little bit and like i said
even doing that a lot of parents
particularly very very young children
who had
mistakenly perceived that this was a
kid's movie
you know took little kids to see it and
the kids were freaking out because it
was kind of like you know
i remember the [ __ ] was pg it was
pg-rated [ __ ]
it was pg um and actually this movie and
indiana jones and the temple of doom
were the first two
movies that those two movies were the
ones that got
um the mpaa to say well we need another
rating
between pg and r so that's where pg-13
came from
this wasn't the first movie to have a
pg-13 rating because this was a pg
i think red dawn was the first one that
had a pg-13 actually but this but this
in indiana jones and the temple of doom
with
you know the heart ripping out and all
that kind of [ __ ] were um kind of the
impetus for making that rating
because they're like we want something
that it's like it's not
violent enough to be an r you know
because this probably isn't violent
enough to be an r
but it's still not really for kids
either it had
humorous elements but in terms of like
acceptability for kids and [ __ ]
i'd put it up there with like
poltergeist yeah
if your kid could handle poltergeist now
poltergeist is way scarier
than gremlins yeah gremlins has
like violent graphic content yeah yeah
yeah
like you know gremlins is violent but
it's
the violence is kind of like played off
as being like funny or like farcical
kind of
yeah um you know what i mean so i don't
think it's quite and plus it's like a
lot more
i mean like i said poltergeist just
seems like a normal family and then it's
like ghosts and [ __ ] so it's like a lot
less
i don't want to say it's less fantasy
based because obviously like a lot of
the [ __ ] that happens in that is just
like way the [ __ ] out there
but i mean if if you're gonna talk about
how likely is it that ghosts exist first
how likely is it that these types of
gremlins exist
i mean poltergeist is like slightly on
more believable you know what i mean
so i'm saying that that's like way
scarier so it's you know
but like i said this is way like a way
funnier
movie oh can we talk too about this is
another thing that i didn't realize
until i watched it last night was that
billy's dad in this the inventor
is played by hoyt axton who i knew was a
country music guy
and then he kind of became an actor
later on
what i didn't realize until i was
watching it last night and was listening
to his voice
was that that is the same singer that
did the theme song
for mitchell with joe don baker
which was on mystery science theater
which was one of like the biggest
like one of their most popular episodes
and he did that terrible terrible theme
song
called like my my my mitchell or
whatever the [ __ ] it was
and it's like because i'm sitting there
going is that that's the dude that did
mitchell because i was like i know that
[ __ ] voice because i've seen that
episode so many times
and then when i looked it up today i'm
like oh my god i thought it was that's
like [ __ ] thing
but it's like the thing okay so the
interesting thing about this movie and
like i said if you
everybody's seen this movie so you know
what it's about billy gets like a
an adorable little you know creature for
his birthday that his dad bought or for
christmas rather
that his dad bought in chinatown and you
know are very very specific rules don't
get them wet don't feed them after
midnight yes i know a lot of people have
said it's always after midnight
somewhere how the [ __ ]
when's the cut off you know what i mean
i just assumed it was like
sunrise like don't feed them between
midnight and sunrise wherever you are
but then people are like what if they're
on a plane what if they're
you know what i mean what if they're on
a satellite
it's like just don't think about it
like i said i just thought don't eat
after midnight and then like once the
sun comes up it's safe again
that's what i thought but you know what
i mean i didn't i wasn't thinking about
it too much
but uh yeah and you're not supposed so
you're not supposed to do any of that
stuff
so the shitty thing too is that like as
soon
like billy has had this tiny little
creature
for literally maybe an hour or two and
it just immediately starts whiffing it
like all over the place it's like the
[ __ ]
you know corey feldman comes over and uh
you know like he does and he just you
know knocks [ __ ] water onto the
poor little thing and you know and then
they well i mean
when they feed him after midnight that's
technically not billy's fault because
they chewed through the wire so the
clock would stop so he still thought it
was 11 30 and he still thought it was
safe
but yeah so one one thing that i had
forgotten about
re-watching this movie again other than
like i had forgotten how upsetting that
was that the dog got hung up in the
lights and everything because i was like
that poor [ __ ] dog
one thing that always kind of dog was
alive though from whatever yeah he was
he was like i said
in the original script he got eaten by
the gremlins so i guess he fared much
better in the actual
uh finalize final movie but one thing
that i thought was really interesting
was that
billy seemed like when he got gizmo
you would think this is a new species
this is an animal that has never seen
and this is clearly a very intelligent
species
because he can kind of talk i mean he
says he says bright light he says things
like that
you know he can say sorry he says uh oh
he says stuff like that so he
and he obviously has some like
human-like intelligence
because you know billy's like playing
the you know the
keyboard or whatever and he's like oh no
that was the wrong note and he's so he
can do [ __ ] like that
i feel like if that was me or if that
was real life
i feel like i'd be like much more
amazing you know because billy's just
kind of like oh cool
and then they just kind of start hanging
out i mean like it's like not even
not even a thing that was also not the
thinking of the time i guess not
no i guess looking at it now i'd be like
that's a whole undiscovered species but
that's not how things work that's not
smart that's not how you looked at
things back then you talked back in
those days if you saw
a ufo right and an extraterrestrial
e.t comes out of there you grab that
sucker you sell his ass
that's how you did it back then i do i
do kind of feel like that some of that
bleeds through because
right it's just look we got it this is
ours hey [ __ ] all these other people
we're going to figure this out
this man had a best destiny [ __ ]
yeah yeah
another species it's okay i got this
dominion over the earth
yeah it just doesn't it did that's what
god said it didn't it didn't it didn't
it didn't
people didn't think that way i guess not
but like i said it's just really funny
watch although i remember like
being kind of weirded out by it at the
time too like even when i was 12.
because you know he gets this amazing
little creature yeah but you have to
remember he got it from the chinese
yeah okay which that explains everything
oh okay
now you understand yeah yeah you got it
from the magical asians
yeah it was just china and it's way far
away
nobody's been there it's been over there
mythical country anything could happen
well it's from china yeah you know big
trouble
i think it is in that in in in in the
thinking of the day
that was that it's kind of like it's
kind of like the joke was this from
snl like the coneheads where basically
they're the cone heads but everyone said
they're
friends and everyone was just kind of
like oh all right that makes sense yeah
so yeah maybe that's what it was well
maybe that's what maybe he was parodying
that maybe he was parodying
it's like oh the mystical orient or
whatever and it's like so they get this
well we believed and also that [ __ ]
kung fu was real that's true
that you know all right true
so yeah if it came from china then they
might have some [ __ ] like that there in
china and then china that's kind of
normal
the little kid sold it he said ah
he's granddad's dumb he doesn't we need
the money
yeah that's just the bug yeah it's like
yeah we got [ __ ] guys
in china china's lousy with them yeah
little maguire ever sickening things
we're tasting it yeah
it's like tribbles kind of i was
actually thinking about troubles
because like they're super cute but it's
like everybody's like yes they're just
everywhere they're up during that era i
understand the thinking at a time
well i didn't see it but it's just like
i'm not saying you're getting too
conscious you're getting two you're
getting two like uh
world conscious behind it this is
another species man we didn't give a
[ __ ] about that
well yeah like i said and immediately
like i said they immediately start
[ __ ] up the rules
admittedly not on purpose really but
he's not being super super careful which
i would be
like because if you know even if it
wasn't like
you know a totally undiscovered species
this is obviously an intelligent
creature like i said he can talk and he
reacts like a human would react
so i can't spell so so i feel like
so i feel like you would be a lot more
careful like you know what i mean to
adhere to the rules of his little life i
just take it to take care
i remember just accepting it well
everybody did yeah
that's what i mean it's just a movie
it's like china and yeah they got that
kind of [ __ ] and they got that kind of
[ __ ]
yeah but yeah because i was saying too
that as soon as like corey feldman
uh comes over and knocks water on your
mogwai which is a sentence i never
thought i'd say out loud
but um you know and and he has that
gross thing where he starts like popping
all those little fur balls
off his back and then they also grow
into bogue and then everybody's just
kind of like
huh like you know it's like nobody like
flips out or anything
and then the dad is immediately well
[ __ ] man let's pour more water on them
and then we'll just
we'll have millions of these things and
we can sell them we'll be billionaires
yeah that's another thing too is like
the mom is
looks like a housewife right i mean i
don't she doesn't like go to work or
anything
and the dad is an inventor but he's a
shitty inventor
i'm like who is paying the mortgage on
that house remember he was doing direct
sales
okay he was walking around just selling
things to random people but i'm just
saying tried to sell an ashtray that's
necklace ashtray
yeah yeah smokeless ashtray so to that
guy he was invented
making it in his own house and walking
around settling these inventions and he
was able to support his family
which is a very childlike concept even
back then
i mean well maybe that maybe that's why
billy had to work at the bank
because he was trying to like support
because his dad was like a loser that
couldn't like make it
well you would you wouldn't be able to
support you wouldn't be able to support
your family and pay for that i know
i i guess i guess it's implied that some
of those inventions are good and he's
selling the ideas to companies
maybe but companies don't need ideas
they have ideas of their own
i just kind of love too like the mom
character in this is so great because
not only is she like a gremlin killing
badass and she's just like not having it
but she's also like really supportive of
her husband's work even though he's
terrible at it like even she uses all
the gadgets even though they don't work
and you don't have to use that that
reminds me of
surviving around this around this era
they're not labor saving
their labor making devices exactly the
the
that reminds me of around this era there
was an infomercial that they would
constantly play on tv like a commercial
during
during the times when like geraldo in
between geraldo and sally jesse raphael
about if you're an inventor we can yes i
remember that
we can help you make it rich on your
great inventions just do this and that
and call it
and you know that was a scam of course
you show up and then you're on a 1-800
number you're they're
talking to you for an hour about your
damn inventions probably racking up
[ __ ]
20 30 bucks worth in telephone fees
then you probably have to give them four
hundred dollars to [ __ ]
make a prototype or something no to
submit the paperwork for your invention
i'd imagine that they made [ __ ] hunt
thousands and thousands of dollars just
submitting
useless paperwork oh i'm sure off of
[ __ ]
nut nuts in their trailers who think
that they have you think that they've
invented like
a big thing yeah i mean a new coat
hanger
yeah it's like i don't want to [ __ ] on
inventors because um to be fair
like some really really dumb [ __ ] has
made like millions of dollars
like sometimes you see some like that
really really stupid like look at the
[ __ ] pet rock for christ's sake
like some guy just came up with it he's
like hey i'm gonna find a rock and stick
some googly eyes on it and stick it in a
cool box
and that dude made like millions of
dollars you know what i mean so
just because the idea is stupid doesn't
mean that other idiots will buy it
yeah most of those inventors don't don't
last don't don't no that's true
but i'm just saying that you know you
can't just you know
you can't just [ __ ] an idea right at the
gate because it's like you you never
know like what idiots will pay for
so but i do feel like the one of the
whole jokes of the movie
is that his dad's inventions are stupid
and don't work and you know what i mean
and it's like and it kills me
it kills me that they're still trying to
use them even when the dad's not there
like the dad's not even there to be like
hey why aren't you using my egg breaker
thing with the chicken head on it
or why aren't you using the orange
juicer that like sprays [ __ ] all over
why aren't you using that you can not
labor savings even when he's not there
they're still using them but i'm like
you don't have to you could just if
you're making orange juice just squeeze
the orange with your hand it will be
like much better
remember that stupid thing these trips
say on tv it was like it looked like an
electric toothbrush with a [ __ ] spike
on the end of it and you stabbed it in
inside of an egg
and it beaded the air inside the without
like why just some stupid [ __ ] it just
seems like really i don't like
those kitchen gadgets that only do one
thing yeah
you know what i mean that's why ronco
kept adding and if you act now we will
also include and they start you the next
thing you know
it's [ __ ] 40 things all for the low
price of [ __ ] 19.99
okay let's get back to the [ __ ] thing
but yeah seriously because yeah they
knew what they were doing they yeah they
definitely did yeah
so yeah um did we even mention that
phoebe cates is in this because phoebe
cates isn't it yeah i mean when i was in
korea in the army
all our katusas which are korean army
augmentations the us army
they're the koreans that work for us the
young korean soldiers
they [ __ ] love phoebe cates well
she's darling they have posters of her
and [ __ ] yeah well she was especially
after fast times at ridgemont high which
came out before this
and actually there was a little bit i
don't think it was controversy
controversy but i think when they were
first talking about casting her in this
everybody's like
well she was the boob girl from fast
times at richmond isn't she a little
racy to be in this one or something like
that but they wanted her anyway
yeah well i don't even think the koreans
knew about that they just [ __ ] had
posters
they didn't know about that and they
still loved her yeah they still loved it
yeah there was something about the way
she looked i don't know i don't know if
she's amerasian or something but they
were just something about the way
that she looked with korean guys in the
in the very early 90s just looking at
she's super curious and that was like
that was like the most famous american
woman
in korea was phoebe kate's interesting
yeah that was i mean she was pretty
famous here too but you know
no that was not in marilyn monroe wow
you know i didn't know that yeah that
was fascinating it was back then
that's cool though i like yeah you're
like definitely we were all we were kind
of mystified like her
i mean she was cute but i mean we like
phoebe kate's too but no
it was like marilyn monroe they were
like or just uh yeah
she's the ideal american yeah phoebe
cates yeah
kind of like their version i kind of
kind of like remember how big farrah
fawcett was in the 70s yeah
that's feather that's swimsuit yeah
phoebe cates was
in korea like like fair foss that's
hilarious
yeah they loved her but yeah so she had
been in fast times regiment high like i
said
and then she was in this movie and i
guess
she like zach galligan the kid that
played uh billy
he was um i think he'd been at a couple
things but he was like a pr
he was pretty new like they just they
picked him because
um him and phoebe cates like had really
good chemistry with one another
but i think one of the things that
people always talk about when they talk
about this movie
is phoebe kate's my dad dressed as santa
and died in the chimney
and that's why i hate christmas now the
funny thing about that is that it wasn't
the original script
because like i said original script was
way darker um
and a lot of the producers didn't want
it in there because they're just kind of
like um you know yeah this is supposed
to be a black comedy but that speech
we're not really sure if that's supposed
to be funny or if it's supposed to be
sad or what are we supposed to be
feeling about it it's like too
they you know they were kind of they
thought it was too ambiguous
ambiguous or too ambivalent or that it
was like too weird like tonally
but steven spielberg he also he wasn't a
big fan of it but he's basically like
look joe dante i picked him as director
it's his movie
so if he wants to leave it in he can
leave it in so joe dante wanted to leave
it in because he's like to me
that speech is like the encapsulation of
the whole tone
of that movie where it's just kind of
like this [ __ ]
it's almost kind of like a sick joke you
know what i mean like it's kind of funny
but then
and they said when they screened it like
for audiences like the audiences thought
it was pretty funny too even though it's
a pretty [ __ ] up story
it's basically it's it's an urban legend
i had heard that urban legend before i
even saw the movie
although it has actually happened a few
times
i don't think i don't remember if it was
um if it was a santa claus
specifically trying to come down the
chimney but i think that there was a
case
or at least one of a kid that was trying
to
get back in his i was trying to break
into a house or something like that yeah
down the chimney and like fell and broke
his neck or got stuck yeah and then like
he did i think it's the same case that
there was a kid that went missing yeah
and find his ass for years
and then they went they either sold this
abandoned house
or they were getting ready to demolish
the house
and uh i think maybe somebody went in
there to move into that house but it was
bad
the house was vacant for many years and
they found his
[ __ ] rotten ass in the damn chimney
can you imagine
i think i think i think the chicken
chimney was plugged and they started a
fire or something in there
they smelled it or man i can't remember
all that well that's what she says in
the
in the story so i can't really remember
i mean yeah you would think
i don't know and now i have to look at
i'm sure that's happened more than once
right i mean he was trying to break into
the house
without breaking in so he just tried to
go down the chimney he was teenager see
that's what i thought too he was trying
to like get back
she was trying to sneak back in because
it was like after curfew or something
right or he or was he trying to break
into somebody trying to break into
somebody oh it was a house that wasn't
owned
oh okay i got you all right it had been
vacant for a while he was trying
it i think it had stuff in it you know
yeah i'm kind of imagining
a place where somebody died and it was
locked up you know what i mean the
family locked it up there was still
stuff in there
he was going to go in there and kind of
burglarize it but he wanted to sneak in
he didn't want to break
any windows or anything to get in so he
just went down the chimney evidently
that's what they think
don't go down the chimney kids and he
got stuck and couldn't get out
it won't ever died in there so he was
probably in there for seven days dying
of thirst
yikes imagine that i mean at least in in
at least in the gremlin story like the
dad like slipped and broke his neck and
was dead immediately
instead of like just being stuck in
there and not being able to get out
because that would really suck also i
got narrow as it went down and you
should
see that's what i i think it depends on
the chimney like i have
you know this is florida we don't some
people have fireplaces but um
you know because like my mom's house has
a fireplace but you don't really get to
use it all that much because it's always
hot as you can see
decoration but yeah it's just it's just
look look
how fancy i can use some room that i you
know that i don't need that i don't know
all right this movie here some people
want to say that this is
one of spielberg's best movies i think
it's a good movie
i don't think it's one of his best uh i
i'd much rather take
red raiders of lost ark or
uh really one my favorite thing that he
did was
probably close encounters i love that
movie i know you do
yeah it would be hard for me to pick
probably raiders of the lost ark if i
had to pick a favorite stephen spielberg
movie
um you know what i mean something that
one's fully encapsulated but there's
something about
[ __ ] that little kid getting sucked
out through the doggy door man
yeah yeah that was pretty cool that
actually used to scare me
was his name barry his mom barry barry
the [ __ ] kid gets to take it up yeah
aliens are like hey i'll be taking that
yeah on him on the way back i always
wanted to see what was
inside the damn alien craft and then so
they added scenes
to show what was in there because
everyone was like what the [ __ ] was in
there yeah it's kind of like what'd your
budget run out god damn yeah
but yeah so this one oh i wanted to
mention too
uh polly holliday in this who i who i
talked about briefly
mrs diegel who is like a gigantic
[ __ ] in this movie she's obviously
supposed to be
a combination of the wiggity witch the
wicked witch of the west especially and
because she straight up says to billy
i'm gonna kill your dog
yeah and you know what i mean i mean on
several occasions
so she's kind of got that going on and
i love how she gets killed in this
it's delightful i mean because not only
this cranky she's also supposed to be
kind of like scrooge too because she's
kind of she owns most of the town
she has the yeah she owns like she has
all the mortgages on people's houses and
everybody's like hey man we're going
broke and it's like can you give us an
extension and she's like [ __ ] you
you know what i mean yeah it should kind
of [ __ ] like that so this is very
scroogey
so i love that they not only have the
gremlins like [ __ ] up her little chair
lift thing like in her house
and she goes flying up the [ __ ]
stairs but they also like throw her head
so she breaks the window and goes flying
across the bucket and they're like
[ __ ] you old lady we're like throwing
you out
like i said it's just it's very funny
that
the 80s were a very different time um
this ostensibly kids movie had all of
this kind of
all of this death in it all of this
violence in it
there was i think at one point because
uh phoebe kate's character she works at
the bar
right and all the gremlins like take
over the bar
and i think one of them at one point has
like a ski mask on and just like
trying to stick her up like with a gun
and the [ __ ] and at the end when
they're doing the big fight with
uh with uh stripe in the department
store
like stripe tries to kill billy he
straight up shoots him with a crossbow
arrow
yeah and then he he hits him with a bat
or something like that and then like he
tries to kill him with a [ __ ]
chainsaw
yeah they're not and he shoots at him
and he misses and [ __ ] like it wasn't it
was they weren't [ __ ] around
it wasn't a kid's movie in the way not
really all kids
it was for young adults and teenagers
and and adults and
you know kids at like 10 11 you know
they like that kind of [ __ ]
yeah like i said i was 12 or 13 when i
saw it and and i really like
i think the reason that movies like this
have endured
um maybe more than any other genre
because this is kind of like its own
genre yes you could call it horror
comedy but it was always
it was kind of like this weird like
liminal sort of movie where it's kind of
like too scary for kids but it's like
not scary enough for grown-ups
yeah well the movie delivered yeah you
were a kid because you know
the gremlins were a threat they were
shooting at people they were shooting
they killed people
they were shooting each other they were
smoking and being bad
and [ __ ] up the theater and they were
you know
dressed one of them's dressed up like a
woman and then i
was dressed up like a blues singer
so you know it's just it delivered when
you were a kid you're like yeah yeah
that's badass oh yeah yeah oh he shot
the other one yeah
yeah he did he shot one of the gremlins
so it wasn't talking down to you yeah
yeah i mean i worked that was the appeal
right like when i was a kid
77 i saw star wars in the theater my dad
took this took me to see it it was this
fantastic
science fiction movie that just really
appealed to kids but it didn't talk down
to you it was like i was enjoying an
adult movie
and understanding it yeah so that it had
that same
kind and like i said it's not you know
it's gremlins is
violent i mean like i said the gremlins
do are actually threatening and they do
actually kill people in this movie
um but in also it's not
so gory and so over the top
that a kid couldn't watch it and like
you said i think that there's like
a really good you know it's kind of the
same liminal space like i said that had
like monster squad and like movies like
that
that are kind of kid oriented you know
or have
like kids as the main characters or as
you know sidelined characters and
but they're not so scary to be like
horror movies but they still like have a
lot of elements in them that kids
would find scary but yeah they'll say
they still don't want it poultry
was a little bit scarier yeah but really
out of all the steven spielberg movies
for me close encounters was the one that
creeped me out the most
because that's presented in a very
realistic way
i think that's kind of what makes that
one crazy it's really although i will
still say that poltergeist is probably
although i think although toby hooper
maybe directed that so we don't really
know yeah
but he pretty but stephen for me close
encounters was a spooky creepy movie
that aliens are coming to get you and
they're controlling people
and then it kind of ends up with a happy
ending they give the people back
and you get to see him and they're doing
sign language
and you're like oh this is awesome and
then they split
[Laughter]
so we just took them for a little while
we just did a little anal
it's fine the build-up to close deer in
the close encounters when you weren't
really sure what was going to happen
well yeah cause you're gonna know like
what these aliens have right yeah
but like i said i feel like oh another
thing too before i before we uh
end and i forget about it another thing
i want to say too about gremlins is that
this maybe you don't catch this because
i don't think i caught it like the first
few times i watched it but i was
watching it again last night
this is kind of a very anti-technology
movie
i guess they were kind of i mean not
only that because you had to think like
the
the dad was an inventor and was like
inventing all the stupid [ __ ] that
didn't do what it was supposed to do it
just broke and everything
but also um the whole thing about the
the mystical asians and and their little
creature
and they said you know just these very
three simple rules
and then you know they they give it to
the white people and the white people
just [ __ ] everything up and everybody in
the town is dead pretty much
it looks like they don't really like
specify but it kind of looks like
everyone's dead
and then you know they have to blow up
the theater and like kill all the
gremlins and stuff
and so then mr wing like the guy comes
back and he's just like yeah you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] this all up i'm taking this
back
you guys are not ready you're like
letting him watch tv he even says that
why are you letting him watch tv
yeah you know what i mean so it's very
very kind of like
well the the message was is that is that
like uh
american consumer the american consumer
culture was not ready
from for access to mugwei yeah
they would [ __ ] that [ __ ] up they did
[ __ ] that because they did [ __ ] it up
they did right
there's like i knew that right so you
know
that that's that's what they were
talking about it is an
anti-technology anti-mass market
anti-consumerism message
uh which that's really what america has
always been
which is funny because they they
marketed the [ __ ] out of this movie
there was like all kind of toys that
this goes back to the times of [ __ ]
robber barons and
and and the railroads and jp morgan and
all these guys
they really [ __ ] america up i mean
they hurt a lot of people in their rise
to power
uh but they also built the
infrastructure of the us yeah so we've
always had a very ambivalent
relationship with right with that and
that's coming back around with big tech
and [ __ ] now people are like man this
technology can be used for evil
what are they gonna do they're gonna use
the [ __ ] are they gonna put a damn
cell phone in your head
and attach it with wires and then
they're going to control you remotely
and and [ __ ] control what information
you can have and can't have
they're going to make you think for
yourself because it's too dangerous
and they make you they're going to think
for you because it's too dangerous
for you to think for yourself that's
that's the kind of [ __ ]
technologies you can technology is a
good thing but it can be
used for evil well it's just kind of
like anything else any new developments
are kind of like a double
here's an example in the in one of the
newer batman movies
batman makes a damn device that listens
to all the [ __ ] spoken voices through
all through everybody's cell phones and
all their
uh technology so he can find
who was it was it the joker to find one
of the bad guys
yeah all right and this thing was like
the ultimate spy device
you could you could find out any
information you want
you want it but in the end batman once
he gets the bad guy he says ah [ __ ] this
he destroys that program
although somebody else will just come up
well that was the morality of then and
that was what
in the uh 2000s you know i think it was
2000
something you know what batman begins
and i think it was the second one after
that
now we have that's called google
basically they do that
yeah and you don't see them turning that
[ __ ] off for for their reasons i
i'm very suspicious of
corporations and their [ __ ] access to
this kind of power you don't even really
want
nation states with that kind of power uh
and
it takes you back to the [ __ ] um to
um
ridley scott's vision of the future with
weyland industries and [ __ ] all these
what was the one from uh from from the
new one [ __ ] uh
was making making the holographic girl
what was the name of that company
wallace was it wallace
yeah just i i don't uh you know i'm
skeptical i'm [ __ ] scared of all that
[ __ ]
yeah if it's bad they'll do it if it
makes money
yeah but yeah so um yeah so
gremlins uh obviously a very um
you know a christmas classic a lot of
people watching on christmas along with
this die hard some other ones
um they did make a sequel to this
obviously in 1990 gremlins two the new
batch
which actually was a lot more of a
comedy but it was actually like a satire
they even
they satirized the first one they
satirized the commercialism of the first
one like all the toys and stuff that had
come out
um and they satirized the very
idea of sequels i feel like i didn't
like the sequel when i
when it first came out like when i saw
it but i think it holds up better today
than it did at the time i think back
then i think people didn't really get
they're like what i wanted more of like
gremlins like a horror comedy
whereas the second one is just more like
a straight-up satirical comedy that's
like making
fun of the first one sort of um you know
and making fun of the like i said the
idea of sequels
you know in general if you like a movie
you want more of that you can always go
to the [ __ ] italian market the
italians
italians would just give you more of
that yeah it's not going to be as good
but no
no not usually they're just going to
rename it like critters
i do feel like gremlins was kind of this
because so many like knockoffs came out
because it was ghoulies there was
troll there was hobgoblins trolls on
mystery science theater
there was [ __ ] uh what was the other
one yeah critters
yeah god damn there was a million of
them lots of lots of knockoff was
ghoulies the one that with the little
one that was coming out of the toilet on
the cover
i think so there were so many like
little creatures go batshit insane
movies that came out in the wake of
gremlins it's just like [ __ ]
hysterical
like to think about most of them bad
well yeah and
in the case of hobgoblins legitimately
terrible
but made a good mystery science theater
episode so i'm not gonna [ __ ] on it too
hard because that's like legit one of my
favorite episodes
because that movie is just so so awful
all right so
uh i guess that'll do it for our movie
retrospective
of gremlins everybody have a merry
christmas
and uh we'll see you on the next one bye
you